school closures in 37 states affect more
than 37 million kids from kindergartners
all the way through 12th graders some
families are struggling to adjust as the
coronavirus crisis grows meg Oliver is
at an empty Middle School in Montclair
New Jersey made good morning we know
your kids are home right now probably
your husband working on their schoolwork
but how about students there how are
they getting an education yeah this is
the time when students normally line up
here in front of buzz aldrin middle
school but this is one of the schools in
New Jersey that has already closed down
as millions of students across the
country log on from home some with
laptops provided by the district and
parents juggle this new world of
learning but it looks different in each
family we're taking this step to keep
our school communities safe public
schools in Los Angeles closed this week
some 600,000 students forced to stay
home the same happened on the East Coast
in New York City where there's a
five-week closure of the country's
largest public school district serving
more than a million students leaving
officials scrambling to assure childcare
for emergency personnel and health care
workers another major concern is making
sure students don't go hungry more than
70 percent live in poverty so free
breakfast and lunch is being offered at
all New York public schools school meals
I don't have to provide which is two
meals
I can provide another day city schools
are also moving to online classes next
week but even the head of New York's
public schools says some three hundred
thousand kids don't have electronic
devices or internet access at home he
ordered hot spots we've teamed with
Apple we've bought laptops we're gonna
have laptops coming in at about 25,000 a
day in Miami Mary Williams is racing to
find child care for the rest of the week
and beyond thank God I was off the day
and was able to come I in to get them
stuff in the e-book for the rest of the
week I won't know every day we're gonna
have a morning meeting in New Jersey
remote teaching started Monday for
several districts need a realistic
fiction realistic fiction substitute
teacher Tricia Angela Lowe has four kids
ranging from preschool to seven
great how long are you prepared to keep
this up the school says two weeks I'm
assuming a month and I think the hope is
this week we get into a rhythm how
overwhelmed are you feeling it's a lot I
think and my kids can see it I can feel
it I can feel the - as a parent Tony and
Gail and Anthony as you all know New
Jersey's governor now has ordered that
all schools across the state be closed
by tomorrow here in Montclair the school
district deployed three hundred
Chromebook laptops to families in need
Gail I know Meg we saw you yesterday
with Cormac Maria and Tommy all sitting
at home being homeschooled
you got good memory yep parents have to
figure it out I know that we got to
figure it out
thank you very much Meg good to see you